今月初め社長ですねちょっと無理やり元気出してみたんですけど
実はあんまりば僕元気がないんですよ
ちょっと強いデコじめじめしてね温度も上がって来てね
なんかね体調があまり良くないんでね今日
皆さんサプリメントとしてますねサプリメントアプリメントっていうのはね
まあいわゆるツイートみたいなもんですよまあ一種のもう
ドラッグするドラッグドラッグじゃないんですよあのお店に行ってきたんですけどその
お店にあったサーブ裏面とか残波しから全種類買ってきました
こういう感じもうなんか色々買ってきちゃいましたちょっと見てみるか
ぱっと見ると子
こんな感じでございますちょっと1個ずつ紹介していきましょう
ブルネイミネラル練度アスタキサンチンタン塩と黒ごまセサミン
ビタミンブレンド攻めラインとです何たんだろう
クロスっぽいですね dna と eba グルコサメポ酸カルシウム+ビタミン d
アミノ酸亜鉛
何て呼ぶくらいアナキャンパーコエンザイム q 10今度はじぇねんあかんだ
アルミ製今夜何か夢不十分と宮蔵そのメジャーな神田店ば今回はですね
このサプリメントとモンスターがいいかな
モンスターとサプリメントで最強のエナジードリンク
もうね本当にこの
ありとあらゆるで栄養素をね一瞬で取り込める
ドリンクをね今日は作っていこうと思います
掃除機
死ぬ気がするんだよな神やばいが同役作ろうかな
1錠ずつこちらの
持った
ものに移していこうと思います巨泉さんにちょっと生ぬるいことボケしたくないんで
全部
黒子と入れていきます
はい今 zepp 位で終わったんですけど
してやばい高齢はヤバイですよ
もう無くんんあーケミカルるっ
それでもすごいですよ
ん
なんか綺麗なアークさぁ全部出したんですけどこっからはですね
まあとりあえずモンスターを入れてみようと思います元気も欲しいんだよ
やっぱモンスターをねこう受けていくことです
ケミカルご覧くださいあーあはと吹いてますよ
者は e うーん
どうぞい
俺元気出るのかなーっていうねこれ今が過熱してきれいなその液体状にしようと思い
ます
では行こうじゃあちょっと加熱していきます
あの者だはいオッケーです
のし場所まツアー
ええっ
ん
やーやーやーやーやーやもうちょっと行ってみましょう
良い別サプリメントは全部
遂げましたん
うん
このままですねはちょっと牛乳+できます
ニュースっと何度もしつこくえんですけど本当に真似しないでください
そもそもサプリメントっていうのは多量に摂取するもんじゃないんであったがインで
これを1回冷蔵庫に入れて冷まします
やめたいん
いこーよ
もう何度すごいですよこんなんですよ2010年で一覧
凄まじことしてる気がします
ではいきますもう実験だよこれ
いただきます
は本当に病は
じゃあも普通に行きます
プー
うん
ええええっ
私がうわぁ
私が実験してうんうんっ
ん
不備の仕掛けでブーンオレガー
実験して
この食生活をわー
ううっうぅうううーさーさーああああっ
うっかりたい派
イェーイウー do
ん
th